[Music]
YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do -
one two nine thirty one five seven three
one that is my texting community
platform doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there and also access
opportunity first looks in that
environment - and to 9:30 one five seven
three one join it now and now to the
video you've been wanting to watch there
are people in this room who literally
didn't want to get a cell phone because
they thought their pager was good enough
or had no interest in an iPhone cuz
their BlackBerry was so much better
my friends technology matters it always
wins
you got your prospective
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I'm really excited it's interesting I
was sitting backstage and thinking about
this talk and I've had the fortune of
having a lot of friends and I've spoken
at other events within the mortgage
broking community and really what's
fascinating about it is it's a sector of
business that I feel very close to
because I have a lot of understanding of
you know entrepreneurship salesmanship
reputation being being a distributor of
multiple products so there's just a lot
of kinship that I feel for this room and
it's interesting as I was walking the
word that was coming through my mind was
actually instead of what I often do in
these talks which is really try to paint
a picture and through sheer will and
motivation and just energy have deep
hope that I can get one two five people
to actually start executing on the
incredible arbitrage that is available
to this collective room to make what
they want to happen which is no matter
who you are in this room you need to
tell a story to compel somebody to do
something with you but what's
interesting is the word that really
resonated to me in the back was
compassion and empathy which is to say
I've been thinking a lot over the last
three months actually how many people
here by show of hands
follow my content somewhat thank you so
so some of you may know that over the
last hundred days or so I've been
speaking a little bit more subtly I
don't know how hardcore you go about
delivery style versus what is being said
and I think all of us as we evolve that
I'm sure for the people here as you've
evolved through your business you Evan
flow and you get more thoughtful
experience matters it's crazy to me how
much of a business gangster I thought I
was at 22 years old and look I walked
into my dad's single store liquor store
and took it from a three to a sixty
million dollar business as a 22 year old
to 28 years old so I had it but to stand
here this morning in front of you
it's crazy to me how much experience
matters I thought I was great and I'm
still that same person I have those raw
talents but I have the great fortune of
twenty years of experience and the great
fortune of listening to the community
and the comments and the feedback and
and I've been thinking a lot about what
the style in which I communicate is it
clouding what I'm actually saying
because I sit every day I wake up every
morning and I think about this room and
I say how do they not understand how do
they not understand that if they post 5
to 30 things today on Facebook and
LinkedIn and Twitter and YouTube and get
anchor and start a podcast while they
walk down here with a coffee and post it
now they have a podcast and like what
what is happening that the 98% that
follow me closely
daily consumed the podcast here this I
mean for the people that just wrote
raised their hand one of the biggest
reasons I'm trying to do so much Q&A now
is I'm saying the same [ __ ] I'm not
gonna change this message it's you know
the the reality is thank God for me
because I enjoy this so much thank God
for me that tick tock comes along thank
God for me that LinkedIn after a decade
of being a recruiting tool evolved into
a content tool had the world not been in
a place where constantly the place where
we spend our attention moves I would
have been irrelevant five years ago
because what I believe after you have
the ability to recognize if it's podcast
or Facebook or not Facebook anymore on
MySpace or YouTube or direct mail or
email or billboards or my ability to day
trade attention I say it down here maybe
it was up before my ability to actually
know right this second
this second Saturday October now not
this year not this era today this second
where the underpriced attention is
whether organic which means every single
person here even if they don't have a
LinkedIn account can go home
after this talk create one and post
something about their local town what
it's been like for her to be an
entrepreneur a product or service which
I don't recommend because too many
people try to sell up front instead of
bring value the fact that you can do
that with no followers no context post
today on LinkedIn and get a thousand
people to read that is remarkable it's
just remarkable the fact that you can
buy Instagram swipe up ads in stories
within a five-mile radius of your office
in the region that you sell at $2 and $3
for every thousand people that see you
is ludicrous so I guess this morning
instead of my normal like I'm gonna
Tasmanian devil this room until somebody
just starts to [ __ ] do this you know
I'm kind of going with a different point
of view of like what do we need to do
here today like like its what has led me
to places like insecurity and keeping up
with the Joneses and judgment and
parenting because all these things have
come to me in the last three years
because I can't put the pieces together
that if you've consumed what I've had to
say on the ridiculous
thank God success that it's brought me
and any other company that does it my
friends the number one advertiser on
Google AdWords from 2001 to 2008 was
Amazon Amazon became the biggest company
in our country because it understood
underpriced attention and it didn't buy
billboard I mean it bought a lot of
things because there was a big company
but they spent crazy money on Google
AdWords when Google AdWords was the best
arbitrage I took a liquor store that was
doing 3 million dollars a year on
$300,000 gross profit before our
expenses with no credit line and no VC
and in 6 7 years built into a 60 million
dollar business because email and Google
AdWords were the right move if you spent
30 hours which I think you should if
this is your business on deeply becoming
educated how to properly run Facebook
Ads not what so many
here have done which has they've done
one little thing with Facebook ads
they're nice did it or some outsource
social media expert did it or they tried
to do it and it didn't work and they
decided Facebook Ads don't work you know
what else doesn't work a basketball if
you suck at basketball let me make this
very simple this is not unfair or
audacious this is the truth if you've
run Facebook ads and they didn't work
you suck not Facebook this is happening
this is happening and so here's where
I'm at in a world where you want to
convince me that I'm better off to go
with you than to go to a.com that is
doing a way better job than you
marketing we've got some work to do like
let's get to let's get to the elephant
in the room if you're gonna get out
marketed by rocket and zebra and schmira
and bee bruh
you're gonna lose I don't give a [ __ ] if
you make a shirt that says brokers are
better I'm being serious that's not a
razz that's not a razz that's compassion
- we need to be consumer centric humans
don't care that's not what customers do
customers didn't care that the local
bookstore had been there for 44 years
they wanted to pay eight bucks less and
have the book delivered to their home
customer doesn't care you have to
understand that I don't care that you've
been doing this for 18 years and have a
great relationship if you get out
communicated over time you will lose
this is a very simple game the internet
will suffocate everything but the
persons and organizations that
communicate best and have the best
product right but the best product is
subjective you don't know that it's the
best product until after the fact on the
communication part you know that Karen
showed up in my LinkedIn and I'm in the
market for a mortgage and I happen to
like what she said in that video my
friends there's nothing more important
right now period in our society than to
be a unbelievable communicator in a
contemporary manner it is reshaping our
societal norms our politics our retail
AB
how how can you sit at home and talk to
your closest friends and relatives about
how this and social media has changed
politics has ruined our children has
done all this stuff and not feel that it
can impact your business that is the
compassion I walk in with this morning
what has been the lack what is the lack
of the bridge that has clicked in your
mind to make you understand the
following which is this is my
fundamental truth this entire room
should be making 30 to 50 pieces of
content on the internet every single day
99% of this room hasn't made 30 to 50
pieces of content this year that Delta
scares the crap out of me and I want to
continue to articulate in this keynote
why and how let's go into the how I
think one of the biggest things that's
running through my mind is how do I
commence this room that yesterday
yesterday not tomorrow they need to
either start a video show or a podcast
that they can then record and then after
it's done for an hour do what I do which
is post produce it and chop it up into
little pieces which then gets them into
a place of being able to make 17 or 20
pieces of content out of a one hour day
now what do you make your podcast as you
guys can imagine no normal human being
thinks mortgage life is rad
we can agree with that it's not the
Lydia thing in society but what I do
believe is the following I do believe
that every one of you has the ability to
start a podcast that is a small business
or community show based on where you
live the st. Louis business podcast is a
real podcast that anybody here could
start and let me break this down to you
why I want to encourage so many of you
to start a podcast I call it the high
school party rule I want to take you
back to high school
now think about sophomore junior senior
year and think very carefully about that
one kid who wasn't the most popular kid
in school but had the great fortune that
his parents weren't around on weekends
that kid as a mid-level popular kid had
the great idea of being the person that
threw the party so the popular kids
could come and hook up and drink that
kids popularity exploded over the next
year or two the person that hosts the
party has the leverage if you start the
st. Louis business podcast show and then
you spend five hours DMing emailing and
reaching out to all the other business
owners in st. Louis and inviting them to
be on your podcast named the st. Louis
business podcast you by just taking the
initiative have flipped the leverage and
now will have much bigger business
owners than you interested on being on
your podcast through that you will build
general awareness in your region and you
will build reputation as a top of the
funnel lead gen to what you actually do
the show is about the entrepreneurial or
local dynamics the awareness you get
from it will allow them to figure out
what you do for a living which will lead
to biz dev I believe what I just said is
as important as knowing how to balance
your checkbook
I believe that in 2020 the ability to be
a media company or a content creator for
your business is as required as paying
your taxes and knowing how to manage
your cash flow I also know that the far
majority of this room and this world
does not agree with me yet and that's
fine because that's a story of my life
the first talk I ever gave in 1997 was
not really a talk it was a panel with a
table about this size in a New Jersey
Chamber of Commerce event in Springfield
New Jersey with like 40 people and I sat
with another guy who was sound as crazy
who was selling Yellow Pages ads and we
were debating I guess in theory the
value between the yellow pages versus
the Internet and now this is important
how many people here under 35 just raise
your hands kids listen to me this is
this is not that long ago this is 1997
listen to me this is me on a panel only
22 years ago right when you were 13 or
younger and I'm sitting debating which
is more powerful the yellow pages or the
entire Internet and by a wide margin
I lost the debate to the 40 people
listening there was even a point where
the guy made a joke and said and guys
let's call it what it is this kid thinks
we're gonna buy wine on the internet
which made the 30 of them laugh and then
one nice man in his 50s was like hey
real quick
so how does this work this is literally
what he asked me I just really want to
understand what I'm doing right now is
contextualizing everybody how far we've
come to let you understand where this is
about to go and why it's so important
for you to really get serious about this
this gentleman asked me if the way I
shipped wine through the internet was
taking a bottle from the liquor store
and in the basement there was some weird
pipe I put it into
and it went to people the first year
right the first year like the first year
the first year I collected emails in my
store when you would come in and buy
wine and I would ask people for their
email because I wanted to build my email
list routinely people would say to me oh
my email is AOL at yahoo.com deep
misunderstood they are people in this
room who literally didn't want to get a
cellphone because they thought their
pager was good enough or had no interest
in an iPhone cuz their blackberry was so
much better
my friends technology matters it always
wins
it doesn't care that you've been
crushing it for 20 years
it doesn't care that you don't like it
it doesn't care that you're sad that
kids don't go outside and play and look
at an iPad it didn't care when it
invented the telephone
or the fax machine or the radio there is
a collective naivete in this room about
what's gonna happen over the next decade
let me paint you a very clear picture
unless you start really listening to
what I'm saying and executing on it you
will not build a brand brand is going to
be the only thing left because let me
show you exactly how I'm gonna buy my
mortgage in 13 years I'm gonna be
sitting in a kitchen in 13 years I'm
gonna be talking to somebody we're gonna
decide to buy a mortgage for business or
at home whatever it may be advice I'm
giving to my niece whatever it may be
and then we're gonna say Alexa get me a
mortgage let's talk about that friends
you think it's tough competing against
people now that are doing a good job
about Google search and Google AdWords
they're not even gonna exist in 15 years
because everything is going to be done
through voice or quite a bit of tedious
decision making tasks the fact that
Alexa and Google home and Apple will
100% be the tollbooth to buying
decisions means you better be in a game
where you're producing so much content
that when I decide I say app
get me Karen Thompson for my mortgage
because if I say Google I need a
mortgage everybody in here is in deep
[ __ ] it's true and so for the 93% that
did not just clap
I'm not doomsday Donnie um get your [ __ ]
together Tommy what I just told you is
not happening tomorrow there's nobody
that needs to cry for us I'm explaining
that I have a lot of concern for you
because I care because I come with
compassion not audacity I come with
compassion this morning because of the
timing of the transition of consumer
behavior to going towards voice matches
a downturn in the housing market that
double-sided front is gonna be a
challenge to navigate through how many
people here are retiring within the tent
next ten years and I don't mean before
you raise your hands and I don't mean
you're gonna crush it and buy a yacht I
mean you're [ __ ] old and finished
hands raise it
yeah all of a sudden it became - I got
you on some serious stuff on some very
serious stuff the fact that so few hands
just went up I want to remind you to
think about all the advancements that
have happened in technology in the last
ten years I mean and if you allow me to
go back 15 now I could talk to you about
a world with no Facebook no YouTube no
smartphone no Alexa no Netflix and guys
are you paying attention
and what cuz you don't want to post on
social media because you've made a
subjective decision that you don't like
it your customer doesn't care if you
like it or not news alert I don't like
it
there's a reason I don't post anything
about my family have I not been in this
business I probably wouldn't even have a
social media account I'm pretty private
I mean I have no love for it I didn't
give a [ __ ] of Twitter Facebook
Instagram all disappear tomorrow I mean
I have no interest in social media I
have interest in consumer attention I
was very very into sending direct mail
in 1997 because the money I put into it
did very well for me and returned from
my dad's liquor store I adored buying
full-page ads in the National New York
Times on Wednesdays food section and
acquiring customers all over the world
for that $40,000 vague once we got
bigger I'm thrilled with email I'm
thrilled with Google the only reason I
like social media is cuz it matters
right now I can't wait to be at a
keynote in 10 years and talk about
social media the way I talk about the
yellow pages
I have no romance my friends I'm just
trying to win and when you try to win
you eliminate your opinion when you're
trying to win you eliminate what comes
comfortable to you when you try to win
you don't rest on the laurels of what
was tried-and-true and got you here
because you know those are the same
things that are gonna make you leave
here it doesn't matter what I did
yesterday and that I can't express how
much passion I have for this room to
hear me this morning
I mean you're here you know what I think
about stuff like this especially on a
weekend conference
you took your time I know Vegas is a fun
place to come to but you're here so if
you're here I'd like to think you're
gonna do something about it when you
leave and listen I've been doing this
long enough at this point that I
genuinely know that right now I'm really
only talking to eight people in this
room I mean that here's what I mean I'm
gonna get you fired up wait till we get
to Q&A which I'd like to get to pretty
soon here so I assume that's the mic
right for the lineup so if you have a
question you should probably start
lining up now I know I'm gonna get you
motivated and excited over the rest of
this next 40 minutes I feel good about
that
that's what I do well I just know that
next Thursday's gonna come around and
you're gonna lose something that you
thought you had or somebody's gonna quit
and you're gonna go to defense I get it
I've been around too long at this point
I get it but I implore you and I and I
hope especially for the hands that went
up this morning that do know what I've
been saying what are you waiting for
like I'm not I'm not putting that
content out for my follows and likes I'm
putting that content out so you do
something about it like you watching me
doing it doesn't mean you're doing it
it's time for you to act and for the
people in here who didn't know who I am
or haven't heard this spiel please
understand that the opportunity is
enormous I am watching people who follow
me go into your sector and many others
with no experience no history no
reputation and grow dramatically because
they're just winning attention upfront
they're funnel is just so much greater
and they're figuring out the back end
customers don't know how good it is
until they try it the upfront matters so
much the opportunity is so enormous I
have been marketing successfully now for
20 plus years I promise you there's
never been a better time than right now
this LinkedIn thing for this audience is
uncomfortably big how many people here
marketed on Facebook in 2011 to 14 and
created Facebook pages and that was a
leader to some good business for them
just raise your hands I just want to get
a sense so for this very small group and
it was a small execution but obviously
for the hands that went up we remember
how good it was
exactly and a lot of you in this room
know that it happened and it was good
and you regret or disappointed that you
didn't take advantage of it I'm standing
right here in this room right now
telling you that exact phenomenon is
happening right now on LinkedIn right
now organic reach at scale at numbers I
haven't seen since Facebook 2013 and if
you have no presence your first video or
written word or audio will work please
call my bluff please just try it will
really work and once you start
understanding how that works what's
really fascinating is what happens next
because you know that you know what I
love about you guys and I know this
about you deeply is once you see it then
you really get going right it's seeing
it it's you need a proof point you need
that first closed deal you get from a
LinkedIn post and once you get that
blood in the water there's a lot of
sharks in this room and so I'm just
trying to give you a boost a push a
well-articulated
debate to why and on and at the end of
the day let me be very clear here I
could care less if any of you do
anything about what I just said
ironically it's in my best interest you
don't these are just one screen for
every post you put it's more unlikely
that I get through to somebody there's
only one stream if I'm trying to sell
wine and you're trying to sell a
mortgage and somebody else is trying to
sell butter it's just one stream
ironically everything I just talked
about I would be way better off
personally selfishly for none of you to
post the reason Facebook and Twitter and
all these things have been flow is
eventually the world figures out how
much underpriced attention there is and
the ads and content go in and then a
plateaus it's no different than real
estate when you're the first person to
see a shitty area on the verge of
turning and you buy up the land you make
more money than the people that come
four years later it's not super
complicated I'm in the real estate
business I just trade attention not land
my friends this is the moment and let me
leave with this because I see there's a
lot of questions and I think this will
be better
for you because a lot of this you can
see free online my friends the last
thing I'll leave you with as you're
thinking for a lot of you in this room
this is one big game of self-awareness
you have to figure out how you like to
communicate not all of you are
outrageously handsome and charismatic on
film right I get it
some of you are great writers and that's
amazing in a world where we're so
focused on video and audio writing is
crushing you can crush by writing great
paragraphs and articles on LinkedIn or
Facebook or things of that nature some
of you love the gift of gab but you're
genuinely insecure of how you look I
understand you don't like to be judged I
respect that
hey I'd like to talk about that but be
then just record it and put out audio
files of your thoughts this is a game of
a do you believe what I just said is
true be how self-aware of you of what
kind of communicator are you the
communication of a human being has been
established for hundreds of years
written audio video and then see are you
willing to put in the work ethic to
learn a new skill that is required for
you to be successful the amount of
people that are not doing this because
they actually don't want to put in the
work for 50 hours to learn it is
fascinating to me and an unacceptable at
some level in the face of the technology
changes that I know are coming to your
industry I appreciate your time thank
you
thank you
thank you thank you I left a lot of time
for Q&A because I'd like to do with Q&A
is get very specific to your in it I can
get very narrow so I'd like to so thank
you for being here go ahead so uh my
name is Marc summers I'm with aim so
think we could be in here very good yeah
our first question is from Jason okay
hey Gary question is about company
culture culture one what would you say
the most important thing is when
building a company culture firing
[ __ ] easy enough
I meet it and the reason I got such a
big reaction is cuz everybody here knows
exactly what I'm talking about that the
number one unacceptable thing to me when
you have control as an owner is to
choose a salesperson that's driving
revenue but is cancerous to the vibe of
everybody else it is a mistake you do
not understand how much hidden money
you're losing you're looking at a two up
front and you don't understand that his
or her 300,000 is actually casting you
500,000 on the back end second half was
as a company scales how do you keep that
integrity of that culture firing
[ __ ] easy enough I mean it I'm at a
thousand people now and I literally
fired one of our number one employees
two weeks ago and that's that like
either you care about your culture
because you understand that's what
you're actually doing and that's the net
of your business or you just say it
because it looks good currently in a
political correctness world and you
actually don't care you just care about
your short-term money I make all my
decisions on my bank account forty-four
years from now not 44 seconds from now
awesome thank you you got it our second
question is from Christine hey Christine
back with the president of 20/20 vision
you had me at your agent 2021 I did a
real estate influence thank you for
having me of course I'm using myself as
an example because I began to follow you
and when I launched the coaching company
I had 500 Facebook friends and I had no
other social media and I had a leader
that was telling me it was overblown in
egotistical and not to get in the game
and I began to watch your videos on
LinkedIn I'm a 50-year old professional
and I thought how am I gonna launch and
grab market share and I just watched and
I listened and I did what you told me I
got authentic and I became liberated and
I said things that were uncomfortable
and now I two years later have maxed out
on LinkedIn have all these things have
you calling me to come to your agent
2021
and I'm here to say all these people
want to get authentic but it's very hard
to do because it's no because people are
worried about judgment and people are
worried about short term economics
people don't say things
because they're worried about their
short-term economics I don't know what
to say they're scared to say something
that may cost them money now and they
just don't understand life is chess not
checkers and everybody's doing things
that are so literal it's so much more
fun to talk about what you believe in I
mean when I first hit the scene wearing
what I wore talking like literally every
person told me not a soul is gonna take
you serious and I was like cool I'll see
you later let's see how this plays out
I'm stunned by people's inability to
understand you know how things play out
whoever's bringing the most value always
wins yeah I want to thank you and I want
to say to tell these guys to take that
crucial first step and be the example
for you so it's more of a testimony but
you know when I took those first steps I
had people in very loud saying she's
gonna fail egotistical bah bah bah and
now we're going to seven figures
let me look now let me tell you
something about winners versus losers
winners don't have time to judge others
thank you anyways think I have never in
my life taken the two minutes to go
consume somebody else's content and
leave a negative review every negative
review I get or hate or troll I feel bad
for I don't feel bad for me you
literally took the time to watch me and
spit venom I feel bad for you so thank
you very much our next question is from
Andy if you're taking questions as you
mentioned a lot of people come in here
and ask for advice and they don't follow
the advice but yes ask holes but what
would you say for such a digitally
evolving industry and we're in a service
industry like we are that's somewhat
saturated if we did one thing one thing
of advice after this what would you say
that would put out 50 pieces of content
a day okay my friend everything is a
commodity you've got it right why do you
think I'm trying to get everybody here
to build a brand the only thing on earth
is not that's not commoditized is brand
do you understand what this little
[ __ ] swooshes this [ __ ] sneaker is
a commodity you and I can make this
right now in China but this [ __ ]
swoosh is worth a trillion yeah
people are [ __ ] confused out here
every one of you is wearing clothes
right now that's a commodity but you
chose it for a reason do you understand
it's only brand what you're gonna try so
much harder for me than the person
sitting to the table next time you get
out of here what you've been doing it
for so long get out of here this is a
commodity you're all in the commodity
business you're a [ __ ] commodity
what's not a commodity is your ability
to make people know who you are
thank you end and this is why it's so
interesting I'm now as I'm getting older
it's interesting to see how my books
came out my first book was crush it in
2009 pretty much what I'm saying right
now thank you my second book was called
the Thank You economy which is really
interesting because the other thing
that's not a commodity is how many
people here after they did a deal with
somebody on a mortgage came back a year
later and called that person and said
hey how are things going or sent the
fruit basket and said hey a year ago we
did business I just wanted to say thank
you that meant a lot to me here's some
bananas and oranges have a good day
that is not a commodity people aren't
doing that here because you're moving on
to the next attack you're in the
acquisition business you're not in a
lifetime value business that fruit
basket that you said that just says
thank you is such an unusual move that
that person also has a niece or an aunt
that's in the market and you get
reminded we don't do that
so the commodity is what you do the
whole game for everybody is room for
hyper growth or massive decline is what
they do upfront and they what they do at
the end all the value is always here the
Middle's the commodity and with the
internet the middle becomes way more
commoditized real real fast and we can
sit and dream what we want the customers
to think or we could start paying
attention to how they're actually acting
thank you
thanks again our next question is from
Chris
hey Gary thank you for taking questions
Christopher Griffith vetted VA one piece
of your content about a month ago
changed my opinion of you okay what's
called a tribute to my friend Nipsey
Hussle yeah one thing that I realized
from my time in the Marine Corps as a
leader is if nothing else he's a
protector and one thing I think that
excites people about you is even though
you're vulgar and you have your
mannerisms ultimately you fight for
those who are disenfranchised I do have
that one podcast led me down a rabbit
hole of many more right now in my
opinion the biggest disenfranchised
consumer that it's identifiable by class
in the US housing market is the veteran
veterans are targeted they're
overcharged they're discriminated
against by ignorance and all of us in
here if there's one alone that we can
place our finger on to say brokers are
better it's a VA loan so my question for
you yeah with such veterans don't go to
the VFW the the American Legion anymore
they're on Facebook in droves how do you
captivate and convey such vitally
important information when it is a sexy
by coming in upfront with things that
disproportion them value and are sexy
build actual relationships and then by
month nine maybe start slipping in
valuable and important information the
biggest problem for a room like this
including myself is when you have sales
DNA the number one thing that we need is
way more romance and patience but people
try to go in too hard and so you know to
your point about nipsey and hip-hop
culture and I spend a ton of time
interactive you know the kind of stuff I
get is you can imagine especially you
know ironically vulgar and alpha
massively over indexes with military
individuals and I get a lot of stuff
it's about actually bringing value up
front joining 73 different Facebook
groups and becoming part of the
community not your opening post is your
being discriminate against let me sell
you some [ __ ] you know what I mean
perfect you understand dude so this is
why I always get mad at the ladies in
the business world who go in for the
clothes I'm like you're a lady you know
this is what we do to you in real life
we try to close too soon slow it down
do you know the insanity that's gonna go
on tonight in Vegas people try to close
too quick so it's by bringing enormous
value up front that most likely doesn't
have as much to do with what you
actually do for a living it might be
mindset it might be sharing content from
other things you like it become part of
community and nu starts lit here's
what's amazing digitally and this is
notice this is similar to the st. Louis
business podcast concept that I threw
out because our profiles have the links
to our business you can go a long time
if not forever without even mentioning
what you do there's people still to this
day when they like to razz me they're
like but what does he do because I don't
even mention vaynermedia all that often
you know and so bringing value to the
community upfront building that
relationship playing it out is if being
a provocateur important in your mind no
I don't think so
I believe it or not and it's a great
question I appreciate your question I
think being historically correct is
important in your my mind I genuinely
believe what I'm about to say I believe
the communication style I was given
makes me underestimated and smaller not
bigger and I always try to tell people
like it's so funny it's how I started my
talk today be careful I'm up here not
because I'm vulgar or because I'm a
provocateur it's because I've been right
for 25 years
thanks again Gary our next question is
from grant so good yeah so most the
people in this room really aren't
competitors with each other our main
competition is the larger giant retail
operation that's it the chase the and on
a recent ask very do you or Gary be show
you and Seth talked about how the time
is now and that's basically we're
telling us right now right and a lot of
us in this room haven't necessarily
started but with all the platforms all
the different ways to get messaging out
there like you said 30 to 50 a day where
can somebody in your star LinkedIn where
the big boys like listen I work with
Chase
I'd and Gilbert's one of my buddies like
I'm watching all this there become
Goliath losses to David every day of the
week when David acts like David you're
not going to outspend
those players on Google AdWords and on
TV and outdoor media and Direct Mail
David's gotta act like David the place
where they can't win is you being a
human being
that's contextual in your general
industry or demo and producing an
enormous amount of content I spend my
90% of my life trying to get the biggest
companies in the world away from making
one video for a million bucks and then
spending ten million of it trying to
pound into your heads watch this by show
of hands how many people here now
predominantly watch Netflix or Hulu or
DB are outside of live sports raise your
hands look at this like the biggest
brands in the world are spending
billions on TV commercials not a human
in here watches a television commercial
if if a commercial is lucky enough to
somehow because you've dropped the
remote get to you if it's lucky enough
somehow miracle commercials actually
getting in front of you the first thing
you do when you know that's happening is
you grab your phone and you look down
they're easy to compete with take it
from somebody who works with them you
just have to do the other part yeah
so that's the where but here's the next
question
how do you differentiate as a local
mortgage book or differentiate from you
know those big players by talking about
basketball by talking about the pothole
on Main Street by talking about their
aunt by talking about them tripping
today by talking about what they learned
today by admitting that they used to be
too salesy and what they learn this week
by talking about their mentor by talking
about the PTA by talking yeah and to
your point brother and I so I really
appreciate the question you think they
don't care people like nobody's gonna
care guys
the reason we sit in traffic is because
we're so nosy we want to look at the
accident we care about everything that's
the point we think nobody cares about me
going to Kmart or me you know talking we
think nobody cares ironically it's the
only thing we care about everything else
is so vanilla the most interesting stuff
is the nuanced part of you I do so much
business because I'm a Jets fan I like
root beer and wine and like all the
nuances and hip-hop
it's the nuances everything I've done
best practices of social media experts
was said to not do stay on brand stay in
your lane don't mix a bet yeah time for
a couple more yeah I'm gonna do a lot
more oh thank you if you if you weren't
invited to be in line and you have a
question get in line now let's go next
question is from Neil Gary I started
following your content about twelve
months ago thank you and I took your
advice and started putting out content
over the first six months I got
literally nothing good I felt like I was
eating [ __ ] good putting out content
every day yes no sales just information
or entertainment one or the other you've
saved by whole morning thank you for
saying that
first two and a half years I did Wine
Library TV nobody watched I did it five
days a week every day keep going so I
almost quit doing it because I felt like
I'm not getting any traction right
you're like my dad Gary guy he's full of
[ __ ] everybody industry's asking me like
why are you doing this you wait
your time right you're getting one like
yeah look like a bozo so I felt like
[ __ ] but then in the last the second
half the second the second six months
pretty the last six months my business
literally quadrupled and my income hot
Wow so Wow
that's so crazy and like people are like
this doesn't work whatever I'm like use
my w-2 okay like it's proof it's
irrefutable so but what I've noticed as
I put out more and more content is that
the consumers have a negative feeling
about our industry for I don't know if
that's from the last recession or what
so how do we as an industry change that
narrative because you're not you can't
boil the ocean you can change the
narrative by what you do be a good dude
okay so just on a local community level
what are you worried about they're like
like you you know your w-2 looks good
like clearly this terrible perception
isn't affecting you now yes - people get
theoretical you want it it's the same
way I think about stuff I want to make a
positive impact on the world it's very
important to me I'm driven by gratitude
of the circumstances and the parenting
that I was given my way of doing that is
not how everybody tells me to do it
which is go fight on Twitter my way is
to instill especially into young men
because I think they don't hear it from
other places things like gratitude and
empathy and kindness and patience
I give them imagery of work ethic and
truth not bottles and models right and
so that's how I plan on doing it I'm not
worried about boiling the ocean one day
at a time one day at a time one day at a
time and then you wake up 40 years later
and you've created a legacy thank you
welcome my next question is from Larry
by the way bro your job is amazing this
next question is from Susan
hey Gary so I understand the concept of
like jab jab jab right hook and uh-huh
and building relationships as opposed to
just going right yep blows and so forth
but when you talk about doing building
say doing one video and/or podcast every
day yeah and then cutting it up into
like 17 yes is posting out and you're
posting that every single day something
different yes different pieces where do
you post your podcasts and your and your
videos versus where do you do just your
social interaction just your Facebook
building relationships being in
different groups
well it's money as a community most
everywhere the right hook is not
necessarily the post and the jabs or
community management I post content to
communicate you post the content to
start the conversation then you
communicate the right hook concept
versus jabbing is when do you actually
ask for the sale after you put out all
these things then you put out 30 piece
of content and just start you go home
you put out 30 good piece of content up
to st. Louis and about that
when's the 31st one that says hey by the
way community real quick I mean I'm in
the mortgage business and if any of you
happen to be in you know in the market
please email me have a great day if you
start with that and you created no
romance
you're not gonna convert as well is if
you put out three or four months that
gentleman prior to you the back six
months worked because of what happened
the first six months you know and so
that's the concept of it so it's not
that you just do community management on
Twitter or Facebook the content starts
the conversation because that's what you
want to talk about but what you may want
to talk about is the little league team
going three games away from going to the
Little League World Series and the whole
towns enamored with it maybe you go down
to that game film it post it say
something about it and now the
conversations happening host the party
not it uh-huh and now you're just making
relationships everything that a lot of
old-school characters in this room that
have been in the business for 20 30 40
years like all the great things they did
going to the local stuff being part of
the community all that stuff that was
exactly right that was hard work that
was like your physical work you can now
do that virtually I'm building community
at two o'clock in the morning
underpants you know like I don't have to
go to everything so that's how I see it
okay and just one quick flip like as far
as the nuts and bolts of where to post
specific types so for example if I have
I got a great website for you that will
answer this perfect G oh oh it's true
though the reason I spend less time on
tactical is Google and YouTube will show
you everything how do I literally you
can type what kind of content in the
mortgage industry works on LinkedIn
enter and they'll be stuff perfect okay
you got you so much next question is
from Michelle hi Michelle I'm like
anyway thank you can you post too much
no let me tell you why you can't post
too much on social unlike email where
you could have emailed too much and open
rates went from 90 to 30 percent this is
the brilliance of social networks I
laugh when people like these social
networks are these social networks only
make money if you stay on the social
network the social networks didn't make
you post racist comments the social
network didn't make you spew hate the
social media didn't show you something
social medias not showing me anything
other than what I want to be seeing cuz
they want me to stay the reason you
can't post too much is if your stuff
sucks they'll stop showing it if it sees
that nobody's stopping and watching and
nobody's engaging you're not gonna show
up it's completely merit-based our
interests with the social networks are
actually aligned so no you cannot a lot
Gary said it's okay and and and more
importantly if you show up a lot it
means that you deserved it everywhere
that's the only thing you want to happen
next question is from Ramona the
important part is when you show up
everywhere is what you want to be
happening happening you know that's the
other key because you can show up
everywhere if you just post babies and
kids you know that's the other part of
that equation
well good go she she's always in my
newsfeed so I want to talk about
Facebook okay first off I love the fact
that you're encouraging us to go out
just learning ourselves instead of you
know finding this company there's so
much noise out there I think what
happens is we sort of shut down and you
know we got ripped off by this X right
you spill a little money and I apologize
for cutting you off but the notice how I
talked a lot about or I snuck in there
today it's as important as balancing
your checkbook or paint like this is not
I'm leaving Vegas and gonna hire my 24
year old niece to do this this is if you
want to be in business you you have to
know how to do this so put in the 50
hours and know how to do it
because then you'll know how to hire
somebody when you want to scale cuz
right now you don't even know how to
judge it cuz you don't know it exactly
exactly so help us get out of the gate
who are the individuals in the
marketplace that you like as far as
maybe art there are I know you could
google it no no no it's not that
it's I don't know I spend 0.00% of my
time looking at what other people are
doing I read the comments of humans
that's it
all I do is anthropology consumer
behavior research through the Intel that
they're putting out on scale and so I'm
not watching what other people are doing
I'm watching you and what you're
reacting to that's why I'm always so
early on things like tick tock or
LinkedIn because I see it happening
because I spend 4 to 6 hours a day
reading what people are saying about my
content or anything that's trending on
Twitter or things that populate in my
explore feed got it not awesome and
that's what you should do because it's
less about me telling you somebody it's
go to your explore page on your
Instagram
click the clinks and see what people are
saying don't look
the content look at the comments got it
next question is from Daniel hey hey hey
I just want to touch on the your comment
on producing 32 so we have a platform
that essentially we deliver very very
high-end content to on a daily basis
ok part of the reason why how we created
this platform is because we were content
creators and we would have mortgage
advisers screaming hey I don't of the
time a ton of the resources to come and
do this so and I'm sure when you said
that there was many people that were
like well how am I gonna have the time
to go out and do that I can answer that
real quick everybody in here spends 3
hours a day on dumb [ __ ] you know it all
right do you know how many meetings or
an hour that should be 13 minutes let me
save you time all of them so that's you
in front of that thank you
yeah but let's touch on the the
resources and the expertise to go and do
that yeah only because so many of our
clients come back and they say man I'm
spending so much time on doing this that
has taken me away from actually
prospecting or closing yep I'd like to
hear your thoughts on that I think
branding always beats selling yeah
you'll spend six months like that
gentleman on not doing as much
prospecting and selling because that's
selling and what you'll start investing
into is branding and overtime branding
always beats selling you know what's
really fun about selling this is where
my life's at when it all comes to you
you know what's really fun about
prospecting is when you don't do it
anymore
thanks Kerry welcome thanks questions
from Brandon hey first I know you're a
die-hard football fan though I don't
know if you guys know but the game of
the week is LSU LSU gang colors there
for you Vayner sports is recruiting LSU
very heavily this year so they're yeah
alright so first statement I want to
make is two years ago I spoke at some
real estate conferences about the big
juggernaut so we're coming to eradicate
and put realtors out of business I told
him Zillow's your enemy all the places
you're buying all of your leads and
feeding millions of dollars to they're
actually gonna cause you to go extinct
and it wasn't well-received the message
was kind of rejected they're making
three to four to one on what they're
spending on their leads but like you
said they're looking 40 seconds not 40
years because Amazon just partnered with
the largest real estate company in the
country
and of course it's click-click clothes
they don't need a realtor and they're
even giving you $5,000 in amazon bucks
into your house that's Amazon's getting
into mortgage next yep so the second
part the podcast it works I started a
small one and I quit doing it for a few
months because I got busy and the amount
of phone calls I got from people asking
where you at when can I come on the show
and the amount of feedback man we love
your show we love your stuff it was huge
and so now we're getting back to redoing
it on a consistent weekly basis so my
question is what's the cost to hire you
to be my guest on my podcast yeah I
right now I'm just so I don't want to
[ __ ] you I used to [ __ ] even but
yeah and the there's only one hack to me
right now I sew my wine brand empathy
wines is off to a ridiculous start the
problem is you know sometimes your ego
gets the best of you and I mean thirty
thousand cases when I should have
probably made fifteen thousand
which would have already put a set
record levels so if you hit up John and
meet at empathy wines that's the one
hack to get me right now
okay everybody has kryptonite mine's
empathy wines that's it
that's what I got for you see hey Gary I
think we have to make this the last
question you sure I still see 5:26 we'll
keep going yeah next one's from Kevin I
got a couple minutes hey Kevin perennial
pyram ji and homeland now proud for
diesel um good to see you again brother
fitzy again I saw you in the photo man
what's good so thank you for coming and
fighting for this group right here you
know you you really give it to them just
plain and simple like the consumer is
gonna do what the consumers gonna do we
do this all the time Kevin you know like
we like I wish that everybody drank wine
39 times a day I I just ordered five
bottles from your wine tech so I ain't
talking thank you you know what I mean
like like like I get I understand that
you want this for you that's just not
how it works good so and by the way I
apologize that point about it you don't
you have no idea what Amazon is coming
to do and not just Amazon Google it's
like people are naive go ahead so so
help this group right here who's so
deeply rooted in their local community
and and who we all do feel we are better
and not a commodity compared to the
online lenders yeah help us get tactical
talk about your four DS talk about the
three people on staff they should have
to actually brand and market I don't
know that they've seen that piece of
content but yeah if you um if you google
Gary the content model if you google
Gary the content model you'll you'll
find what you're talking about you know
it's just too detailed for me to like I
need 24 you know this that's why that's
the thing we do is a full day but it's
real its tactical and it matters it's
gonna be brand I'm telling you right now
the Boise thing is really gonna [ __ ] you
up I mean it I don't know what else to
tell you we're all gonna order our food
through it our services like it's going
to be a
big deal I'm telling you I'm screaming
from the bottom of my heart in this room
if you don't build your name as a
reputation and have it come out of my
lips you're gonna be stunned how much
carnage is gonna like Toys R Us
you know borders bookstores I mean it's
gonna be longtail
it's gonna be local it's gonna be local
guys like it's coming thank you for
fighting for us thank you thank you
thank you for seeing that I am questions
from Richard hey for the people in the
back I've got a little extra time
because of my schedule so if I'm not
screwing up your programming just add
how many minutes to the clock if any we
have thanks cuz I answer as many as I
can
good Gary how are you Richard Wong I'm
with a Veridian mortgage and cg
financial so you talked a little bit
about the next biggest thing being on
LinkedIn and tik-tok so not next current
current but it's important keep going I
have a 14 year old daughter and yes I
told her I'm gonna start putting content
on tik-tok and she said please don't
yeah but specifically would be coming
from the mortgage industry yeah
can you elaborate a little bit about the
tic-tock opportunity the kids that were
in college when Facebook came out and
the parents said they were gonna go on
Facebook they said please don't and the
parents didn't because they thought it
was college kids and then they woke up
three years later and it mattered if
tick tock becomes the next Instagram
it'd be a really good idea for you to be
on it and if it does not and it becomes
the next vine the things you would learn
by producing content for it will help
you with the next thing that is going to
become the next Facebook LinkedIn and
Instagram real quick what is it and by
the way one of the most exciting things
about being a parent is to embarrass
your kids
do it on a daily basis real quick what
is your most cherished baseball card
that you still own right so cherished is
90 Lee Frank Thomas because that reminds
me of my golden era as a kid dealer from
a business standpoint
besides posting on LinkedIn and starting
a podcast the number one piece of advice
financially I have in this room is to
buy vintage basketball cards they are so
grossly underpriced and the next decade
people can make real money thank you
welcome I know that was a super
left-field comment but but I'm selfish
to d-roc where are you there you go oh
you know I'm gonna clip that in 9 years
when an article from the journal comes
out the basketball cards have gone up
4,000 percent in the last decade so
gotta do some [ __ ] for myself go ahead
thanks for your time we really do
appreciate it next question is from Dave
Dave hi Gary my name is Dave Coyle
coming to this conference has been
pretty eye-opening for me kind of seeing
myself in perspective to a lot of other
many many other way bigger fish yes and
I've been forced to kind of be honest
with myself good and if I'm honest my
biggest limitations have been really
staying hungry and doubting myself ok I
wonder what advice do you have for
staying motivated and positive and for
maintaining a useful mindset that's a
great question
I think it's practice I think it's
perspective you know I think you have to
practice not valuing other people's
opinions insecurity comes from over
valuing other people's opinions it's a
framework that was instilled in you
through parenting and environment that's
just the truth and DNA so I think it's
practice like for example the reason I'm
so happy all the time
this is give me a little left-field is
because almost on a daily basis I
imagine my parents dying my children
dying I'm being serious with you and I
know this is again a little left-field
but it helps me put things in
perspective how can I be upset a bit
about a bad speech or a business deal
going awry or something stumbling if I
actually felt this morning and I don't
think it's meditation but I think it's
closer to it than I even realized even
as I talk about it now I just genuinely
practice brother you have to practice
every day saying
whose opinion do you care about if you
fail you know one of the reasons I love
losing is cuz I don't care about
anybody's opinion in here about my loss
it's my loss you worry about what you're
doing and most people don't have that
framework which leads to insecurity if I
came here for example and I was in your
position and I was auditing all the
bigger fish what goes through my mind is
I'm gonna kill these [ __ ] fish not oh
they're better like you know it's just a
perspective it's kind of like life right
now if you choose to and you only want
to find negativity and bad it's very
easy if you choose to and you only want
to find positivity and optimism it's
there it's it's getting into a framework
of changing the way you look at stuff it
really is it's not naivete it's not
delusion it's real life so you need to
practice you can practice bro it's hard
to be here just because there's some
people that are doing it better
there's also billions of people that are
doing it worse the hell are you worried
about the [ __ ] thousand people here
they're doing it better what about the
[ __ ] 10 million that do it worse
next question is from Fredo hey thanks
for being here
I'm gonna be here I totally buy into
what you're saying about the content
putting everything out okay I'm a
private person that I love to put out
things that help people to help them
grow the judging but there's a part of
me that I want to keep private
brother I've never posted a piece of
content of my family everybody posts
everything about their family because it
gets likes you're a hundred percent in
control good don't post it totally get
that okay but when I see influencers or
I see people just have a camera crew
following them and they that works for
them okay the [ __ ] is that to do with
you well that's what I'm asking
it's no different than the last question
like what I do or somebody else does or
influencer does or what works for her or
him has nothing to do with that with you
if it doesn't work for you it's gonna
break anyway there's no right way to do
it there's the right way for you to do
it talk about bananas all day I don't
give a [ __ ] okay you don't need to talk
about your private life I don't I don't
talk about my private life at all I
meant it when I said earlier had I not
been in this business just the story in
my life I didn't drink any alcohol cuz
my mom Nancy Reagan got to my mom so
alcohol and drugs like I was clean as a
whistle
if my dad wasn't in the liquor business
I know for a fact I would have never
drank alcohol in my life and I know for
a fact had I not been in the
communications business I'd be sitting
in the audience today with not a single
social media profile because I have
nothing to share with you
I'm deeply private in my personal life I
have a lot of business thoughts I have a
lot of observations
I'm deeply interested in sharing what I
got because I know the world is abundant
and I like the feeling of impact and
admiration and legacy because I probably
going to eat and it's not going to come
out of yours or mine so you're in
control good and brother brother as soon
as your sentence turn to but I see I
knew that you see that's it as soon as
you look at anybody else's it doesn't
have anything to do with you totally get
it cools me next question is from Mason
a little shaky but I've been big
follower of you and I hear
you're a big you're a byproduct of your
parents and that they instilled you have
the empathy and the positivity and we
fill the pipes and you talk about an
exuberant amount of content that we have
to fill so I want to ask you someone who
feels that they have it all going on and
knows that they are very successful
besides selling all your giannis rookie
cards and besides buying the Jets what
would provide you value just like we see
the people that are providing culture in
the retail environment and they're
providing these they're they're very
wealthy what how can I reverse engineer
that on social media to show them what
we have to offer and I want to ask that
by what how can I provide you value you
provide me value if you go and execute
on what I just talked about I'm gonna be
good on my thing empathy whines I need
to sell yeah but other than that in real
life just go execute listen I live for
admiration brother I figured out myself
in the last half decade I'm like why am
i leaving so much money on a table why
am i leaving so much money on a table
I'm like alright when somebody grabs me
at the airport and says they were
homeless and they were watching my
videos and now this good thing is
happening or they used to beat they're
coming the [ __ ] that I get bro I used to
beat I mean
sent it I used to beat my girl and then
you got in my head and made me see life
like that feels better to me than extra
zeros in my bank account that's me but
Lee and I'm gonna say something crazy
right now this important and if that's
not you that's awesome that means you
didn't get those chemicals and if you
want zeros do you but this is one big
game of self awareness how do you bring
me value go execute and send me the
email in seven years of how it worked
definitely and you've totally changed my
mindset to be way more positive I'd fill
the ears of positivity so a second can I
get up on stage and take a picture with
you yes
no no question yes you're on video I
know let's take a video man what's up
video all right our next question is
from de Haan hey what's up Gary Thank
You Man for every throw you looking
super sharp you you're super sharp I
love your kicks out rock a little don't
master or look good so what advice would
you give the younger version of yourself
knowing what you know now when it comes
to I would look that kid in the face and
said you're gonna do it just go go go
like I had to figure it out I I had it
figured out and by the way I stand here
as someone who's driven by gratitude
that me having it figured out is the
luxury of my parents having sex at the
right moment and then me being fortunate
to be born in the Soviet Union and
coming to this country with nothing and
having a mom that was cheap for a poor
person which meant nothing was ever
given to me and then the compassion to
want to give back to my parents so then
I built a huge business for them and at
34 years old after never paying myself
more than $100,000 a year on a business
I took from 3 to 65 million I left with
nothing and started over so you can
imagine when I tell the kids to be
patient how easy that is for me like
what would I tell that kid you [ __ ]
figured it out bro yeah honestly you
honestly the one thing is cuz I really
went a little rogue I don't think I
think everything is best in balance
I definitely probably should have had a
little leisure in my 20s cuz I worked
seven days a week
66 and a half days a week like I I took
no vacations I didn't hang out with my
friends so I probably took it a little
too extreme you know I probably would
like to have a little bit more memories
and fun of my 20s but honestly I'm
incapable of like having that regret
given how it's going and so that's where
I'm at
last question big ask my youngest sister
her name is donessa Johnson she loves
you she recently got diagnosed with
cancer would you mind doing a quick
little shout out for her 100% I really
appreciate that yeah
that's it look how sharp he is first I
write Vanessa I miss Vanessa Vanessa I
see Vanessa I'm here with your
ridiculously good-looking brother I just
want to send you my love I'm sorry that
you're going through this challenge I
appreciate you consuming the content and
DM me let's chat a little bit I got
nothing but love for you
it's mindset play your mindset on this
one mindset is stunningly underrated
love you sis says thank you everyone
thank you for having me thank you thank
you thank you so so much have a great
conference